so now um we'll get to the most
challenging piece of all of this in some
ways which is the fact that this is not
happening in in a bubble it's happening
while another country is on track with a
very different political system a very
different economic system and going to
in all likelihood be the largest economy
in the world by the end of the decade of
course you and I are talking about China
are you someone who looking at a medium
to long-term projection would be betting
I mean all of the things equal let's
leave aside that you're an American
citizen all the rest
um just as a capitalist would you be
betting more on the Chinese system than
the American system or even the Western
system large long term at this point
well I I can say the following it's not
so simple
um I think um if the United States was
at its best
um it's a hell of a system but uh
they've got us outnumbered you know
there are four times more than four
times
um as many Chinese as there are
Americans and so that means if per
capita income goes to half what it is in
the United States China will be twice as
large so China
um and China is growing at a faster rate
than the United States is so most of
those things say what you have is a big
effective competitor I started to go to
China I know China very well over uh
since uh 1984 I started to go and when I
when I first went there
I would bring 10 calculators to people
they never saw anything like that
leaders of companies and and government
officials and they thought they were
Miracle devices and now in Quantum
Computing and Ai and so on they're
competitors since I started going there
per capita income has increased by 26
times the life expectancy has increased
by 10 years the poverty rate has gone
from 88 percent to less than one percent
it's certainly a powerful competitor
okay and in that regard and it's and
it's a bigger country and bigger means
more powerful too so that's a tough
competitor and I don't know that we are
the United States is is doing its best
in terms of being an effective
competitor in its various ways in many
ways yes but in many ways no because
we're also at each other's throats and
we have these Financial issues and so um
at the end of the day it will be just
simply a matter of who is most powerful
and most powerful will really be
primarily determined on how we are with
ourselves